This universe is only one of
an infinite number mr strange
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
doctor strange multiverse of madness video marvel
just released a new trailer with a bunch of new
footage of all their big fight scenes and during
it they actually featured some really cool scenes
of doctor strange actually encountering the real
vashanti another group of powerful gods that we
haven't seen in the mcu before but that are really
a big deal in the comics this is obviously
connected to everything that's happening on
moon knight and thor love and thunder with all
the gods of the mcu so we'll break it all down
because the movie's coming out next week we're
doing an imax ticket giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and post all your
theories about doctor strange in the comments and
i will be doing full videos easter eggs for the
entire movie as soon as it does come out there's
a couple new scenes in this trailer but i'll
talk mostly about the big stuff doctor strange
actually meeting the gods as a character doctor
strange is mostly concerned with the mystical
matters magical matters so he encounters many
different types of gods all across the multiverse
but the ones that he's most closely connected
to in the comics are the vashanti and when we're
talking about gods in the mcu for instance like we
talk about moon knight we talk about thor love and
thunder we're typically talking about the lesser
gods the one above all is meant to be the one true
god like capital g god of the entire multiverse
he's so powerful we will probably never see him
but usually when you're talking about all these
lesser gods they're supposed to be a different
version in every single universe for some of
the really powerful cosmic beings and some of
the gods though there's like one version for the
entire multiverse this trailer kind of makes it
seem like there's going to be one version
of the vashanti for the entire multiverse
but for instance there's many different
versions of thor that's how you have the thor
core in secret war so it's not the same for every
single type of god not me what just listening
in the scene where dr strange and america
chavez are falling through this sort of
liminal space through different universes is after
they've gone on the run from mcu scarlet witch
america chavez has started punching holes
through different universes so they can escape
and it's after they tried to use the book of
the vishanti in this special room here that
they feature in pretty much every single trailer
we've seen because of the screen x expanded format
trailer where there's a bunch of extra footage on
the right and left sides we got a much better idea
of where dr strange has actually been keeping the
book of the vashanti locked up or where the other
sorcerer supremes before him had kept it notice
when they opened the metal door to this place it's
in all the trailers they're in a basement but
when you see the expanded version of the scene
in the screen x trailer on the right and the left
you can see that it's in the same basement of the
sanctum sanctorum that we saw during spiderman
no way home that cluttered old basement with
the washing machines and just all the extra junk
that they keep around even the extra beard dye
kit that dr strange had kept around gotta keep
that magical goatee all trimmed up a torture rack
that is a pilates machine even though they said
that they used that basement in the movie like
it's meant to be this common regular old basement
that anybody would have it's actually connected to
the undercroft that part of the ancient temple
that the sanctum was built on top of the temple
was built there at the intersection of a bunch
of really powerful magical ley lines that exist
through the earth that akamoto himself would have
used back in ancient times some of these walls are
thousands of years old and they shot an episode
of the equalizer here in the 80s there's magical
doors and portals to all kinds of different
places inside the sanctum so this isn't really
a surprise like of course they would have a bunch
of magical doors to really crazy places we haven't
seen before but the vashanti are a huge deep
cut from the comics they're the gods who grant
dr strange all the magic that he uses to power his
spells in the comics the relationship between him
in the vishanti isn't quite the same as the
relationship between moon knight and khonshu
but the vishanti just like the other gods can have
regular avatars and do in the comics but usually
they're other people it's not doctor strange in
the first doctor strange movie the ancient one
kind of brushed over a lot of this in the vashanti
just in general during her tutorial just saying
that they take their energy from other universes
and other dimensions to power their spells but
it's a little more complicated than that like even
scarlet witch who uses chaos magic got it from
somewhere it just didn't come out of nowhere like
there is a god of chaos inside the multiverse that
sort of granted her power when she was born in the
comics that's cathone he's one of the elder gods
he also wrote the darkhold it sounds like it's
going to be a little bit different in the mcu but
it's the same basic principle but the vashanti are
a trio of gods who are either old gods or somehow
tied to them in some way or biological children
of old gods the old gods were created by the
sentience of the actual planet when it first came
into being like the planet itself has this soul so
to speak it gave birth to a bunch of old gods when
it was created millions and millions of years ago
the way they talk about khonshu and his pantheon
of the ennead technically they're meant to be
different in the comics but they talk about them
like they are part of the old gods so to speak
in a more broader sense but the actual old gods
are specific group in the comics the vashanti are
made up of ashter hogath and agamotto the same
agamotto who created the eye of agamotto that
doctor strange has been wearing and using this
whole time in the mcu he was also earth's first
sorcerer supreme before he embraced his heritage
and became one of the vashanti if you're a big
star trek fan it's sort of like sisko on deep
space nine embracing the fact that he actually
was born a god and then becoming a god later in
his life it started with oster she was part of the
legit old god she had all these crazy powers when
she was created her personality was kind of like
sersei's in the eternals movie she really liked
lesser life form so she went traveling around
just experimenting with life in general across the
multiverse eventually she met hoggoth who was the
god from this other completely different pantheon
of aliens because she was so powerful eventually
agamotto was born from one of her tears and then
he just existed kind of like a more mystical
powerful version of thor thor was the son of a god
so he was born with all of his powers but for a
lot of his life he lived on earth amongst mortals
but eventually he just embraced more of being a
god and just continued on because he's just going
to live way longer than most of the people that he
hangs out with agamotto had a similar origin
story it just happened in ancient times just
long long time ago for instance agamotto was
part of the avengers 1 million bc team with
a younger version of odin long before thor was
ever born agamoyto studied magic the multiverse
is immortal he became sorcerer supreme created
the whole magical order that dr strange and wong
are a part of he built the temple that you see
in spiderman no way home sanctum's built at the
intersection of cosmic energy currents we weren't
the first to seek him out eventually he embraced
his god-level powers and joined the other members
of the vishanti to become sort of like a god of
order in the mcu they're also kind of like the
gods of magical order like if you think about
the nature of scarlet witch's chaos magic like
the forces of chaos all the different types of
magic that you see in the mcu the different colors
the different types of powers exist in a sort of
balance like you have the forces of chaos chaos
magic you have the more orderly gods trying to
keep chaos from destroying all of reality that
is the vishanti the book of the vishanti that we
also see in this trailer scene contains basically
all the most powerful light side good magic spells
in existence that's why in the movie all these
previous sorcerer supremes going back to agamotto
would keep it locked up in this special
multiverse place separate from the rest of
the library in camartage and why he would try
to use it to try and stop scarlet witch with
her chaos magic which just seemed so much more
powerful than any other threat that he'd faced
but like if we're talking about sam raimi here
doing a horror movie inside the mcu if someone
whipped out the necronomicon to talk about evil
dead army of darkness easter eggs started using it
the vashanti are kind of like the opposite of
that the guys that you would turn to for help
like i said the vashanti are able to have actual
avatars like you see khonshu and moonite in the
mcu but in the comics agamotto's actual avatar for
example is a completely different character called
cadaver they're probably not going to have him in
the movie so that's why i think they're going to
change some of their backstory in the mcu like
i said one of the big differences is it seems
like they encounter them when they're traveling
through different dimensions different universes
so it sounds like they're gonna say that there's
one version of ashanti for the entire multiverse
which would mean that they're way more powerful
and most of their efforts are spent trying to
protect the main mcu dimension that's why in all
the mcu movies if you look at the windows on all
the different sanctums you see them inside this
room here too the different symbols of all the
sanctums they're meant to be symbols representing
all the different members of the vishanti
and they're part of the enchantments protecting
the planet from extra-dimensional threats like
the symbol on the new york sanctum is the actual
symbol of agamotto himself for those of you asking
about connections to thor love and thunder and
gore the god butcher trying to kill all the mcu
gods yes eventually gore would want to kill the
vishanti the whole idea is that gore starts out
with some power the necro sword but as he kills
more and more gods he convinces some of them to
do what he wants them to do and he gains even more
power then he can kill the more powerful gods and
it just scales up from there so it'd take him a
while before he killed the more powerful gods but
eventually he would be able to do that too but if
you have any questions about what's going on with
the gods during the doctor strange multiverse
of madness movie or in all the trailers just
write it below in the comments it'll be similar
to what you see in the moon knight series and
what you see happening in thor love and thunder
but obviously a different group of gods to signal
for an audience with the gods is to risk their
wrath now it makes more sense why they're doing
all this god level stuff in the mcu all around
the same time all these different movies and the
disney plus shows are coming out at the same time
dealing with gods my full moon knight episode 5
video will post this week just like normal after
they release it so make sure you enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss that everyone
click here for my moon knight episode 5 trailer
video and click here for my new guardians of the
galaxy 3 announcement and more trailer easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!